I'm Ash Ketchum.
I came from Pallet Town in the Kanto region.
And this is my good buddy, Pikachu.
Nice to meet you.
Hi, I'm Sarah Natochenny.
I'm a voice actor.
You probably know me best as Ash Ketchum on Pokemon.
I'm also Delia Ketchum,...
...and Staraptor and Misdreavus.
Today, I'm going to be showing you my process for dubbing Pokemon into English.
Pokemon is a show that's originally voiced and animated in Japan.
So when the show comes to me,...
...my job is to reinterpret it for an American audience.
For demonstration, I'm gonna do them together.
Ready for it?
I guess.
Hey Mom, I'm back!
Hope you had fun, Ash.
Sure did.
We went diving with a Sharpedo, saw lots of Pokemon I've never seen before.
Yeah!
And that's how I dub Pokemon.
So because the English dub is so widespread,...
...I'm getting emails from people in India and Bangladesh...
...and Russia and Japan and Brazil...
...thanking me for helping them learn English.
It's amazing.